[Music]
okay
did you guys hear about that maine the
state of maine
wedding reception that is now linked to
the deaths of
seven people who didn't even attend the
wedding is it ronan yeah
from the ronas oh my god how big was his
wedding rona related
so it exceeded the 50-person limit they
had about
a lot of people 65 people at this
wedding
and you know just 15 over i know i'm
like
would they have not caught it if it was
exactly 50 people
or maybe less people die yeah six it's
like
four yeah oh no oh but yeah maine has
reported
less than 5000 cases of the virus in
total since
march uh but because of this one wedding
now a whole bunch of
cases are getting linked to this one
wedding and
six people came from this one
rehabilitation facility that
they were residents at this
rehabilitation facility
and none of these six people attended
the wedding
and the it seems as though the contact
like tracing the contact there is
because
one employee that works at that facility
lives
in the same household as someone who
went to the wedding oh [ __ ]
yeah that'll do it damn oh yeah so how
many degrees
a separation is that two one three or
two
three i think right sounds like three
because six people died
wedding one employee from their roommate
who
went to the wedding mm-hmm yeah it's
like that
yeah so crazy so six out of the seven
deaths is because of that
damn what about the one extra one i
don't know i do not know but i do know
that
that extra person also did not attend
the wedding
are they finding that the people that do
that wedding or something or is there
any like
that's a good question i don't i'm not
sure but they're they just keep
reporting like another
another one is linked to this wedding
and it just seems like
i'm like dude who the [ __ ] got married
yeah dude imagine being that
couple was and if they're like it was a
good party though
oh no no it was the time of their life
no just kidding they weren't good dj
some good tunes were fun fruit was okay
yeah yeah but um yeah imagine like your
wedding being forever tied
like yeah the day that was supposed to
be our special day
killed a bunch of people indirectly yeah
indirectly kill
people yeah that's crazy but then it
also like
leads me to think like [ __ ] it kind of
i mean yes it is obviously directly
linked to this wedding but then if you
think about it
like all these cases are somehow linked
somehow
right like to something to one event or
another yeah we should blame the guests
that came what a [ __ ]
yeah and when they were sick yeah no
what i'm saying is like how
it's just all pinpointing to this one
wedding where i'm like there's so many
other
other events that have been going on
that are probably linked to a ton of
other things
to me i just feel like damn that really
sucks that it's just
this one wedding that's getting [ __ ]
yeah why are they singling out this one
it's because it's an example because
they went oh also that it's like
it's considered one of those super
spreader events you know like you're
breaking the rules to the point where
it's like it's affecting more people
than it should
like i see in a situation that you might
get like a couple people sick now it's
like a bunch of people
yeah i think it's because of the fact
that they went over the limit that
they're just getting like more
scrutinized
for the fact that they had 15 people
over that's the limit
i know like the moment that um
california started to like open up just
a little bit
my neighbor like down the street had
like a huge ass house party and i saw a
bounce house like coming my neighbor is
still having a party
yeah and like the whole street was like
filled with cars and i'm like
we just opened and y'all are partying
right now
and i'm like um like i can't have this
wait are you coming or not like what's
up
no no no no no no and julia saw the
bounce house and she was like downtown
it is outdoors yeah it's air it's
ventilated yeah
no no there's a lot of people there's a
lot of cars and i'm like wow
i can't believe you guys my neighbors
haven't stopped parting the entire
[ __ ] time
yeah really oh david corona party
not even got to be a weekend every day
is a weekend to them so it's been a
rager
are they one of my people uh you
actually spoke to them through the
window
one time at my house yeah one of my
people so you know are they nice people
he was really nice okay have you had to
use your uh megaphone my bullhorn
bullhorn knox and stiff came over
nice really did he calm down he calmed
down like a [ __ ]
there's a cat i helped there's a cat
next door to me who used to play
loud loud music constantly so loud that
we couldn't even watch tv or anything
yeah
and i use it so i bought a bullhorn just
to be like hey [ __ ] your music dude [ __ ]
you
that's a great way to solve your
problems with your neighborhood wow
hey they're at war with you you got to
be at war back right that was my
mythology
with fire was very kind to him and uh
i guess there was a language barrier
that i wasn't even aware of and so then
she was able to make him stop yeah so
when i peeked out of the window
like i ended up seeing him he was
cleaning out his car whatever but he
parked like right next to their window
and but there's a fence but still it's
like right there and then he's just
blasting this music and i'm like
[Music]
like he was just like not looking at the
[ __ ] no he wasn't chick talking to me
he wasn't making eye contact with me at
all instead like it seemed like he got
embarrassed or something because he was
just like oh
he lowered the music and then i still
wanted to get his attention to thank him
so i'm like
he's good back and then i tell him like
oh you know thank you so much
i'm sorry just my friends live here and
this is their their their living room
window we're just trying to watch a
movie and
music is kind of loud really appreciate
it thank you so much and now he doesn't
do it he doesn't do it
so he plays his music but it's way less
way way less which is not bad at all
yeah i think a lot of people just don't
know how much they're affecting other
people
especially if they're doing something
outside they're like whatever you know
what i think it is too he probably
thinks like dude i [ __ ] love this
song
who doesn't like that he's like it's my
answer he's like oh my neighbor's like
hey [ __ ] you and [ __ ] your music
[ __ ] you hey just shut your music off
you piece of [ __ ]
but that didn't really work um so you
probably thought that you were just
jamming out
everybody says at the concerts yeah he
knows he knows those are like part of
the lyrics that's right
yeah because like it's there so if you
know what
what i actually did was play eminem uh
through our alexa
and i would turn the music all the way
up and open my window and then he would
stop
after like a minute of that but that
worked better than the bull horn ever
ever did but then tiff actually
neutralized the whole
you really did use a bullhorn yeah yeah
but i wasn't as bad at what did you
really say what i really say yeah
uh what's the racial epithet for mexican
[ __ ] i guess that's supposed to sting
i love being called up i'm like hell
yeah i love beans
i've never seen someone so gung-ho for
beans dude i was obsessed with beans
when i was a kid i [ __ ] love
like all kinds of beans uh specifically
refried beans are my [ __ ]
but me too they're really honestly
with that with a cheese on top of it oh
yeah so then like when a kid at school
would
that wasn't mexican trying to like give
me [ __ ] for it and be like oh you
[ __ ] beat her i'm like yeah i am a
peanut i [ __ ] love peas
what do you know that's cute that's how
you beat trolls anyway
that's true it doesn't even like i love
it actually they're like this is boring
move on
yeah yeah but anyway so
back to this wedding yeah um so they
were also saying that
the wedding was officiated by this
pastor
who is still like he's maintaining
doing these uh what are they called
attending
attending to these masses right and
and so he's saying like you know this
church has a legal right to meet
and no matter what you can't stop us
from meeting and
they're not doing any like social
distancing at all so then it's like
i don't know the writing's on the wall i
think i saw like a video of
like uh i think he was a priest or not
i don't know uh but um he was at a
church and he was basically telling like
everybody at the church be like
uh the rona can't really stop us and
it's like it's fake
and then he got sick and then he died
from the roanoke did he say plandemic
though that's my favorite one
i don't know pandemic that's my favorite
it's a plan it's a planned
duh uh you see the viral video recently
of the people running through the target
oh yeah there's a bunch of people who
are anti-massacres going through the
target and they're like
everyone take off your mask be an
example to these kids we have a bunch of
kids with them
and they're like be an example take off
your mask breathe
freedom was a really small group though
yeah but yeah i mean they were yelling
really loud but it was like kind of yeah
i was just like
you know when they were marching down
the like aisle i expected to keep seeing
them because you know how you see these
big demonstrations like more and more
people come it's kind of impressive like
no more than 10 just 10 people
yeah it was like four or more kids at
the end of the day do i think that my
mask
is saving lives no but do i wear it
anyway yes like it's just about [ __ ]
being polite and [ __ ] dude
like doing the right thing because maybe
it affects like point three percent or
who knows
three percent six percent who cares just
[ __ ] do it because it's
that's the right thing to do true like
we don't always have to have the same
ideology but
just having respectful courtesy that's
pretty cool it's polite yeah
he [ __ ] so like those target people who
are like
be an example to these kids like did
anybody follow through with them no
everyone was just recording them like
you know what might have been great
is that they've planted some of their
own people in the target crowd as a
shopper
and i'd be like you're right like they
said
[Laughter]
that would be pretty great though that
would be a viral hit yeah i would just
be very confused
and then they break out a thriller or
something like that wow
but the the modern day equivalent is
that all the students rip off their
masks they get on
their desks and they say oh captain the
captain and then robin williams dies of
coronavirus
no as a result in the movie
oh but the fact that he's not even alive
oh my god well i didn't know
his name from the movie do you no
okay it's the captain i don't remember
which movie are you talking about
a dead poet society all right cause i'm
a
yeah well crafted my captain that's the
only scene i remember that's the only
thing i remember he gets
fired and that's it hmm
that's a good uh spark note on that
movie yes it's an american classic
yeah but i feel like that would have
been more effective
they actually had a flash mob people
yeah planted like at least
plant like to make a point at least or
like their point
their own stupid point i mean the weird
part was just the kids part
like they were like be an example to
these kids don't you want to be an
example to these kids
they're like yeah that's why i'm keeping
it on yeah
idiot were the kids lost were they like
no the kids were just like oh this is
fun
were they wearing masks or they weren't
no that was part of the family part of
them it was like
it looked like a family and maybe a
couple friends that
i saw that and the kids were coughing a
lot oh no oh god
you know like i i felt like i had to
stop watching like videos that
were like related to coronavirus because
there was just one where there's this
guy that was shopping in costco and a
costco employee was stopping him from
shopping there because
the guy didn't have a mask on and so
this employee was like sir you need to
have your mask on
in order to continue shopping here and
then the guy was like
oh like look look look at this employee
he's not letting me shop here
uh because like i'm just not wearing a
mask like well i have my rights to like
be able to shop here without one
and then the guy was like no i mean it's
costco policy we need you to wear a mask
and he was like oh you're you're on
camera with like my 3 000 followers
right now
oh i saw that one that [ __ ] theory to
me i was like
[ __ ] like you better [ __ ] put your
mask on and he was like oh look at this
guy he's already taking my groceries i
can't even shop and i'm like
you're so [ __ ] dumb dude costco is
like a private store
and they have their own rules the same
[ __ ] is no shirt no shoes no service we
have the right to refuse service to
anyone ever complaining about that sign
you dumb folks like i mean except for uh
fast times at westmont high
original i mean i thought 3 000 was like
gonna affect oh 3 000 people are
watching me right now you're right you
could shop
yeah i don't know i just i just hate
[ __ ] like that i'm like
come on don't don't bring other people
into your own agenda
play ball dude get your groceries get
the [ __ ] up
[Music]
you